this is an all hands deck game what does
that mean
that means you have a 12-man bullpen
only one guy will not see action today
and that's for sure that's johnny cueto
pisses six of the third last night
everybody's ready for this game take
care of business first don't be worried
about the brewers you got to win this
game that is essential and oh yeah by
the way
who are the brewers playing they're
playing the cardinals on the hill today
for the giants will be
the veteran drew smiley smiley is 31
years of age he's in his ninth year at
the big league level this is what he has
done
three three eight here he's still
looking for his first win but look at
the strikeouts 32 strikeouts
in eight against eight walks and 21 in
the third innings two and two pitch
curve ball there's one strike three
swinging
saw a strong beginning for drew smiley
two strikeouts three up three down
on the hill today for the san diego
padres will be the 21 year old
left-hander from
havana cuban adrian morihon morihon in
his
first year at the big league level 511
225 pounder
lifted into right field a base hit for
yostremski
as he waited nicely on that offspring
pitch and it's a
one-out single myers 14 home runs 38
driven in
and he hits a high blast to left
and gone and myers has done it again to
the giants in this ballpark there you
see the hang right up there at the belt
he's a good mistake hitter and once
again he proves it just a remarkable
bounce back 2020 for will myers
i mean these numbers are big
and his contributions are significant
and meanwhile who's out in the cove well
it's
uh hunter and lexi hence yeah
how about that you found a way to uh to
motivate giants and giants fans come on
out to the cove
so two down and mauricio dubois here's a
drive dubon drives one deep to right
field way back there
it's off the foul pole a home run
mauricio dubois hit it right above the
309-foot side and off the foul pole
to tie the game 80 degrees there's no
wind you've got carry in every field no
protection from the wind
and heaven said all that you cannot take
away anything from this effort by de
bond high fastball up and away
he catches it with back spin and then
it's just a matter will it stay fair
off the foul pole four bagger touch a
ball brand new game
manny machado will lead off against drew
smiley who's been very sharp
game is tied at one
a little pop-up
and it's going to have to be crawford
because dickerson going gonna get there
too late
and brand-new crawford does it again oh
man that's a great play he had to go a
long way
i mean just a little fly pattern he's
going out there and you've got
a runaway beer truck coming at you full
boar from left field with
alex dickerson you do not want to run
into him marlin to strike out victim
number three by smiley back into second
so now for the third time this year drew
smiley has racked up
eight strikeouts in an appearance his
career high is 12.
hit well the left dickerson's going back
he can't get it it's off the very top of
the wall
it's going to knock in one and the
padres take the lead that's pretty
impressive and bad for portland
he almost knocked it out of here here's
smiley to the plate
and he struck him out swinging with the
curveball nine
strikeouts for drew smiley in four and
two-thirds innings
so mateo at first pro far at second
and big pitches all under duress in what
has been a stressful inning already
for drew smiley and here's smiley ready
he throws
and he struck him out swinging with a
cutter
tenth strikeout but five innings
and that may be all for smiley slater
will step up it's
no balls in one strike and he drives
this one out into triples alley
but out there and reaching up and making
the catch is myers
myers who has excellent speed and he
needed every bit of it and a good jump
in order to catch this one
and in the end he makes it look rather
easy but
boy he really got on that ball quick the
runners advance yaz over to third
and dickerson to second the pitch felt
swings at a ground ball and a second
out in shallow right field mateo's got
it
throws him out and so it goes for the
giants
a walk and a hit batsman but they come
up empty so
here's mateo three for 24 at the plate
in his big league career
obviously very limited opportunities
this one's going to hurt if it's a fair
ball
and it is and it's going to bounce over
a run's going to come in
and runners will be at second and third
and he pads the padres lead
things are getting dire for the giants
in the air down the left field line on
the move is dickerson he'll make the
catch
and go into the wall tagging at third
and scoring his profar
and the padres will take a 4-1 lead but
that extra run
is huge and that'll bring up myers
down the right field line yostremski
over and he can't get it
and that's going to roll into the corner
mateo is going to score
nola goes to third and it's a double for
myers
and the giants are watching their
chances here and what has been such a
fun
2020 season slip away one out one on
and it brings up brandon crawford
crawford hits a high drive to right
myers back looking up out of here
so there's your answer it's 5-3 critical
at-bat swinging there's a high drive
down to right field line hit pretty deep
still going way back there and it's a
fair ball and looks like a home run to
me
and now the first base umpire signals
home run
so wilmer flores goes deep to start the
inning
and that leaves it to austin slater who
has not had a hit today he's old for
four
that is straight three hundred miles an
hour and strike three for rosenthal
strikes out the sign in order and the
padres win it five to four
that is it the giant season is over the
slater took a pitch that was a few
inches below the knees